we've heard a lot of different facts
about how Puerto Rico is faring in the
wake of Hurricane Maria and while
President Trump says Puerto Rico is
doing great
I only believe what I can see with my
own eyes and touch with my own no
problem down there sized hands why I
flew down to Puerto Rico to find out the
truth about Trump's recovery efforts
myself take a look
I've watched Berto Rico faced an
unprecedented amount of damage after
Hurricane Maria but I was impressed by
President Trump when he swung in paper
towels at hand and he cleaned up that
mess to his own rave reviews we have
done an incredible job
what is your death count as of this
moment 17
sixteen people I give ourselves a 10 a
10 a 10 so I headed down to gather thank
yous and see Donald Trump's perfect
score first hand window Nico 10 on its
head
10 out of 10 and the cables are more of
a six probably like a three Jesus you
don't even know what that is that's
that's probably like a two okay so if
I'm keeping score we're probably
averaging out to about a 6.5 but if you
round up that's a 10 baby and in the
neighborhoods of San Juan people are
even back to work specifically kids
these kids organized getting generators
for this community center so it has
power to teach other kids it all by
themselves didn't need adults help
probably should offered my help
I should they got it no anyway these
kids were working hard but not in school
because technically only 40 percent of
the schools are open and sixty percent
of people have no power half a million
people are without clean water but still
I could tell this was a good news story
right DHS secretary Elayne Duke I know
it is really a good news story in terms
of our ability to reach people and the
limited number of deaths that have taken
place limited number that makes it
almost sound special but some people had
their own narrative dammit this is not a
good news story unbelievable mayor crews
should be saying thank you but instead
she's on the warpath
I wanna confront mayor Cruz to talk to
her about some of the language she's
using
communicate with our President Donald
Trump this is a 10 out of 100 which is
still a failing great there's no power
no communications no phones and no
electricity is that a 10 out of a 10
it's tough for America to get supplies
here you can't drive a truck here I
don't know if you because we are an
island surrounded by water
lots and lots of water exactly ocean
water exactly
we didn't know that until this happen
don't you think you need to go totally
what the most powerful country in the
world can't get their logistics together
I don't think so I saw pictures and
you're out having fun swimming and he's
out there making deals on a golf course
helping people it may give you a
distorted way of looking at things yes
Cruz is one of those local never Trump
errs who's continually pushing the false
narrative that texas or Florida got more
recovery money than Puerto Rico that's
actually a lot more Donald Trump when he
came here God that man is a disaster
what a man protects people after a
disaster not my president well he sure
is you voted for him all right as a
cleric and was not permitted to vote
what is she even talking about back up
what is a Puerto Rico treat me like a
dumb American who knows nothing about
Puerto Rico Puerto Rico is a u.s.
territory precarious territory basically
abandoned but yeah this is America it's
like a Cuba and definitely no it's not a
cube but the Guam and probably in the
sense that we were neglected by the US
government but yes as long as we live
him on the island we are not entitled to
vote for the President or our duly
elected representatives in Congress
apparently Puerto Rico is part of the
u.s. its people are citizens but they
have no voting rights
what's worse Puerto Rico is suffering
under crippling debt and they are
legally forbidden to declare bankruptcy
unlike cities in the mainland you ask
where that happens
time on top of that there's this the
thing that Donald Trump can do is
declare the law the Jones Act no just
scrap it the Jones Act is an obscure law
that says all goods transported between
American ports must be carried by
American ships which means foreign ships
coming to Puerto Rico either pay big
tariffs or reroute to mainland us where
they transfer the cargo to a u.s. ship
and all those dollar signs are paid for
by the people of Puerto Rico making it a
fortune to rebuild I don't want more I
just want equal you know this talk your
history feels like a lot of you guys are
just looking behind you where I'm
sitting beautiful 10 out of 10 maybe I
don't know hmm okay maybe there was more
to this recovery than I initially
thought I think I'm starting to put it
together
Donald Trump said it was a tan he wasn't
talking about his response he was
talking with the response he inspired
he's always thinking a couple steps
ahead so many steps often he's behind so
that leads are called trickle-down
responsibility people in the community
well they're the ones who step up they
come together and they fix the problems
they move forward as a people and thus
become that much more United we all know
Donald Trump he's uniter you see it here
getting lost wandering back to my hotel
because there was no GPS Wi-Fi or
streetlights I came across this a
generator powered bar of people finding
community
I saw this over and over in my time on
the island families filling carts with
supplies to deliver to hurting
neighborhoods we're survivors
but right now we still need a lot of
help people adopting long-forgotten pets
to get planes to ship these dogs soup
kitchens popping up and close
restaurants to help hungry people in
neighboring towns he's like you don't
see down on wait to be fed you work for
it you work hard there's a famous quote
I don't know who said it but it's like
give a man a fish and he will eat one
day helps teach him how to fish and he
will eat forever
that's Reagan smart guy the people the
politicians the cooks the animal
rescuers the kids that guy I think I met
him earlier they are the 10 out of 10
that Trump was talking about it seems
like a lot of people doing small things
was making a big difference it made me
think a lot about myself I wondering if
I could do something like the bare
minimum great reporting Jordan hey there
hey mr. commander-in-chief this message
is for you your heroic near efforts have
inspired so many people in Puerto Rico
to step up and take actions for
themselves and for that you deserve a
big thank you so we brought you back a
gift from the island to show our
gratitude this is Izzy one of the many
abandoned animals we saw down there is
he's such a good girl or boy I don't
know I wasn't allowed to have pets when
I was a kid and Izzy is ready to be the
official first dog of America you say
you're the first president in a hundred
fifty years to not have a pet at the
White House
now some lefties are using this against
you saying it's evidence of your lack of
kindness and empathy and that you'd
never be able to take care of something
that doesn't immediately benefit you
by adopting Izzy you can prove them all
wrong and who knows a good photo op with
your new furry friend could get your
approval rating back in the low 40s
where it belongs
yeah and Izzy if he is so excited to
come live with you aren't you girl or
boy she's such a good girl or boy so
come pick Izzy up our only request is
that when you do you'll tell us about
your plans for the island we'll take
care of her or him here at the
opposition until you're able to stop by
but it's not just Trump everyone can
take a little step to help Puerto Rico
recover here are a few of the many
sources where you can get more
information on how to support ongoing
relief efforts in Puerto Rico the
opposition will return
[Applause]